fake Jam crostini with creamy burrata
and a hearty Maine of beef cheek Ragu
with Papa Deli
80s just think the size of your little
cheeks yeah imagine the size of a cow
with them and the cheek is right
underneath here yeah
I always give them a really nice season
put salt and pepper on there please so
beef cheeks very cheap they cut that
takes sort of a long time to cook yeah
but give it a bit of love let it cook in
the oven it comes out like a dream a
little touch
of oil in the pan what we want to do is
get them really nicely colored shed see
it into the pan oh cool layaway
see what that is
um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the
beach beach
and then I want the onion chunky because
we're gonna cook it for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
and then again there and there so it
doesn't overcook
so a really good color on the cheeks
like that so how do you cook these at a
restaurants if they take so long they go
in the oven literally half past six
seven o'clock in the morning three and a
half four hours ready for lunch and the
longer you leave them in their juices
yeah and the cooking liquor the better
King eyes closed the garlic good onions
in and garlic in please nice where's
your Bailey there it is
get those onions and that garlic really
nicely colored
put the cheeks back in place right red
wine in cool okay the red wine is going
to deglaze the pan so deglaze will
basically sort of rinse all that flavor
off the bottom of the pan yeah okay
because that's going to make the most
amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree but
chopped canned tomatoes you'll make a
much better sauce I'm gonna top that
with some stock so the secret of
braising is having little of the meat
exposed and 90 of it submerged see them
now yeah
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out the water turn the gas
off and leave the lid just off at the
end there if we had to cover it
completely the steam hits the top yeah
the lid and all that water comes running
back it's solar still that's right in
the oven
140 150 for about three and a half to
four hours good job
Boom for pudding I'm making one of my
absolute favorite Italian desserts Banna
cotta with that quintessentially Italian
flavoring espresso
start by immersing two leaves of gelatin
in cold water and leave to soak
into a small saucepan add caster sugar
cream milk
sugar and a shot of good strong coffee
gently bring to a simmer and remove from
the hob
[Music]
wheeze out the soaked gelatin leaves and
stir into the hot cream until completely
dissolved
pour your cream mixture into a jug and
fill your molds just short of the rim
rinsing your molds in cold water before
filling will make it easier to get your
panna cotta out once it's set
[Music]
leave in the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
[Music]
to make your cinnamon hazelnut brittle
pour caster sugar into a pan and cook
over medium Heat
until the sugar melts to a deep golden
brown
[Music]
scatter toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel
dust with ground cinnamon and leave to
set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm given each
mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
thank you
[Music]
dress with a Shard of crunchy hazelnut
brittle nothing could be so deliciously
elegant
right Captain Jack quick run through
Panna cottas are nearly set beef cheeks
I need it cooked we're going to now do
the Fig and brighter crostini oh okay
let's take the figs we're gonna make a
nice slightly spicy fig Jam take off the
tops yeah in half and each half into
three sugar a touch of salt in there
okay we're making a jam but we don't
want a bit too sweet and then these
little babies
what are they
ah what's the shape stars star
underneath taken from the fantasy plant
yeah and when you dry them like that so
intensifies the flavor really important
to count how many put in there okay yeah
so one two three four five so they're
just there from flavors and take them
out that's right secret here let's get
that camera going so when I hear a jam I
don't think of caramel no but this is a
very fast champ caramel's starting to
color
I want you very carefully to drop the
figs in there good
so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the camera
you know what that is I'll sweep it in I
love that on my challenge you've got
that sort of sweet and sour flavor leave
that cooking for three four minutes
now let's slice out chapata in Italian
crostini means little bits of toast but
it could be made out of leftover
baguette sourdough or any crusty open
textured bread we're staying
authentically Italian with ciabatta
season them and then drizzle a little
touch of olive oil on there both sides
really important because we're going to
grill the bread push it down
it's a lovely very lovely take it off
with the chapata toasted we need to
carefully extract the star anise pods
from our piping hot fig Jam
my Jack we've got one little bugger to
five oh no
is it there yes it is right now we've
got the green light to crush
[Music]
skins disintegrated in that caramel that
looks so nice
oh Jack carefully spreads the crostini
with our hot fig Jam I can unveil the
last element to our starter the creamy
Italian specialty borata
a little money bags
looking delicious
this looks fun doesn't it
we need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest can you imagine that sat
there and you tear some of that off and
you stick it on top of that and
back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks I've chosen to use
papradelli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salt and first good olive
oil in
pasta in
twist it round so you don't break it no
bring that back up the ball that's going
to take that through for four minutes
flat leaf parsley scrunch it up for me
yep and chop him now wait to see these
beef cheeks beauties
look at them
they're very soft tiny I'm going to
taste
um
it's so good
yeah you've just dribbled on your jumper
really
right drain the pasta
salt pepper
pasta little drizzle
of olive oil
I'm going to put your fresh pasta nicely
chopped nicely chopped
in
this is the magic bit okay you take a
little Ladle of the juice
put that at the bottom
cook
the pasta
on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
going to love you even more now you know
what about when you cook this for your
girlfriend one day uh just tell her we
got the recipe for money promise promise
I don't want you stealing Daddy's
Thunder
one
beautiful jaw on there two beautiful
Jaws on there
and then the third job and then you go
over
with the source how cool is that
delicious you've got the borrasa
and I've got the cheeks
let's go baby
don't be cheeky get it
my ultimate Italian dinner
quick fig Jam crostini with creamy
borata a main course of slow cooked beef
cheek Ragu with Papa Deli and for
pudding espresso panna cotta with
cinnamon hazelnut brittle
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best Italian
tradition
first a hearty starter or bruschetta
with ricotta and succulent griddle
courgettes for my main I'm serving
fragrant roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto
[Music]
but I'll be in trouble with the kids if
I don't do it but
so I'm enlisting the help of my youngest
Tilly to rustle up an indulgent
chocolate and lime mousse with crushed
raspberries
so if you want to wrap the chocolate
start breaking up in Little Bits we're
going to make the most amazing white
chocolate mousse our first job is to
bring half of our cream up to the boil
so what kind of cream is that in there
dad that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich chocolate
mousse what's your favorite sort of
chocolate is it white milk dark
um I love white and milk what's yours I
absolutely love milk chocolate oh that's
my guilty pleasure is it really here we
go cream in
so that goes in there now you can see
what's happening straight away can't you
it's melting really quickly melting
really quickly so okay oh excuse me at
least your Jumper's white so you won't
spot it yeah I've got a nice little snap
for later
in another Bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks the
lime cuts the sort of richness of the
cream and that starts to make the
chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter
zemus you're absolutely right next add
to the melted chocolate mixture
because I'm whisking it's just getting
lighter and lighter and lighter
have it all taste
nice yeah the line gives it a really
nice taste Tilly I need the rest for the
mousse
I need some for my tummy no come on
chocolate mousse into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites this is where I need you at
your absolute best okay because to whip
those whites it's going to be really
tough so we'll take it in turns 30
seconds each okay you go first
second's gone
come on silly
three seconds gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three two one and change
excellent hold the ball right no
no way
[Music]
come on it's over dad
Matilda
you can't do that to me 30 seconds
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
foreign
a contentious whipped egg whites will
make our mousse light and Airy and when
they've reached soft peaks we can gently
mix in our cooled white chocolate and
cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yeah
the chocolate sets the egg whites keep
the cream nice and fluffy and you get
this nice light mousse in the bowl now I
needed to crush some raspberries please
with some fresh mint
you can see all the juice coming out
now take your mousse
wow that looks really cool now look at
that down the bottom
crushed raspberry delicious now I'm
going to set that in the fridge if you
use the can I open the door please our
yummy white chocolate mousse will take
at least two hours to set so we can
crack on with our Mediterranean inspired
vegetarian starter griddle courgette
Ricotta and mint bruschetta
for this recipe you'll need a griddle
pan an essential piece of kit for that
char grill look
cut thick slices of chapata bread
drizzle both sides with olive oil
season with a little salt and pepper
and griddle each side until toasted
then slice a couple of courgettes
diagonally into half a centimeter thick
pieces drizzle and coat in olive oil and
season with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the courgettes are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy ricotta cheese
spread your toasty to your pattern with
dollops of minty Ricotta and top with
your seared courgette
super simple and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto I'm going to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now I've
even made a risotto
shallots please into the pan for Daddy
add a Sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic once you start cooking the
risotto it's really important
to have your stock gently boiling away
if you're adding cold stock on top of
the rice all the time it just slows down
the process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of Cooks at different temperatures
what stock is that in there dad because
that's a vegetable stock yeah because
you can't have different stocks if it's
for a vegetarian can you no I made that
mistake once putting beef stock in the
vegetarian soup
no I didn't Matilda
I'm positive I'm joking
fly off the time how nice is that smell
s rice in
this is Arborio rice it's a perfect rice
for risotto now it's really important to
sear
the rice if we were just to put the
stock in without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for Daddy
no flambe on the risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
I'm adding red wine followed by the
first Ladle of stock to get things
started now we're off wow it's giving it
a cloudy sort of look
[Music]
what's happening to the stock
is reducing down and the rice is sucking
it in that's right so the rice is
actually getting nice and plump while
the risotto is live when it's like this
now we can't stop cooking it we have to
cook it all the way okay ready for the
next ladle
good girl here we go Ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way
eight words
pill them brought them a little bit of
salt and sugar yeah and a little bit of
aged by some vinegar in there roasted
them I'm a great
my parmesan
how's that Rice doing rice is doing good
no
no where you want to be now look look at
that nice glossy textured rice so
beetroot I want you to put two thirds of
the beetroot in there for me saving one
third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
again and then we're just going to get
some nice butter in there the butter
gives the risotto a really nice gloss
look at that beautiful
come down let it come down first
and then after Daddy
okay there you go good wonderful shaking
risotto should be like lava
just
flows out and then the rest of the beat
room on top
[Music]
and some extra virgin olive oil
that I'll pick up the bruschetta you
take that to the table okay
let's go die
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta
an anxious roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto
and put an indulgent white chocolate and
lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries